dix personnes placées en garde à vue
samedi mais seulement 3 en comparution
immédiate au tribunal correctionnel
trois personnes qui comme la loi le leur
permet ont choisi le renvoi de leur
jugement le tribunal s'est donc contenté
d'examiner leur personnalité et la
surprise
les trois prévenus sont accusés de
violences et de rebellions mais aucun
état véritable casseurs pas en tout cas
le portrait qu'on en attend c'est
l'effet groupe qui allie des gens
ordinaires qui se sont vu s'opposer aux
policiers et aux forces de l'ordre et
qui n'ont pas vu où étaient leurs
limites parce que justement il ya cet
effet de groupe
les policiers en ont assez effectivement
il souhaiterait ne pas être le
réceptacle de toutes les haines et de
toutes les rancoeurs des personnes qui
défilent de n'ont aucun antécédent
judiciaire et pour le troisième une
femme de 46 ans et sont très récents
elle a ramassé une pierre et a mimé le
geste de la renvoyer sur les forces de
l'ordre
un autre chauffeur de bus le seul
véritablement inséré a récupéré une
grenade lacrymogène pour la relancer la
seule chose qui les unissait une
détresse sociale pour deux d'entre eux
une faiblesse psychologique pour tous et
c'est des gens qui ne peuvent pas
s'exprimer parce que personne ne les
écoute parce que chacun souffre en
silence chacun souffre dans son coin et
je pense que cette mobilisation dont
chacun pensera ce qu'il voudra sur le
fond parce que c'est pas la question qui
se pose mais ça a été pour certains
l'occasion d'extérioriser cette
souffrance alors avec plus ou moins de
de haine avec plus ou moins de violence
deux prévenus les hommes sont placés
sous contrôle judiciaire
la femme elle sera mise en détention
provisoire son avocat va demander sa
libération considérant qu'au regard des
faits cette décision est sévère pour
cette mère de deux enfants
tous trois seront jugés le 25 janvier